If you walked away from Jurassic World: Fallen
Kingdom with a bit of whiplash, don't be alarmed.
The sequel easily feels like three different
movies crammed into one, and each act could
presents its own unique horrors before the
big finish brings everything together and
swiftly smashes it all to bits.
Taking place three years after the events
of Jurassic World, it takes some suspension
of disbelief to get our old friends Owen and
Claire back to Isla Nublar, and the visit
goes just about as smoothly as one might expect.
That's just the start of their troubles, too,
as they face even bigger monsters on the mainland.
Let's take a look at what exactly happens
there at the tail end of Jurassic World: Fallen
Kingdom, and tie together all of the film's
plot threads.
A bedside betrayal
The introduction of deep-pocketed dino philanthropist
Benjamin Lockwood explains how Hammond could
afford the original, outrageously expensive
Jurassic Park.
He's also a friendly face for the new Isla
Nublar expedition; one that can convince people
to join in, especially those who were involved
with the previous massacre.
Lockwood plays on Claire's desire to save
these dinosaurs from certain extinction by
the island's erupting volcano, and she in
turn plays on Owen's personal connection to
the raptor Blue.
Lockwood may have been sincere about saving
the dinosaurs, but his smarmy assistant Eli
Mills is much too greedy to simply rehouse
these animals on some tranquil island.
Instead, he's ready to round up whatever creatures
he can to auction them off to the highest
bidder.
At the same time, he's also working with mad
geneticist Dr. Wu to create an even more lethal
and valuable — weapon of war called the
indoraptor.
This thing is a hybrid of the indominus rex
and the velociraptor, and even more menacing
than its parent species.
Once Mills' true intentions are discovered
by Lockwood, he decides to smother his longtime
benefactor to death and go about the business
of turning his late boss' passion project
into a personal fortune anyway.
What a guy.
A particular taste
Mills has no trouble rounding up buyers for
his new menagerie of monsters.
Blue was the VIP target Claire and Owen were
recruited to save, but it wasn't a charity
mission at all.
Owen's behavior research with Blue is important,
because the indoraptor Wu has created won't
work as-is.
He wants to make another one that grows up
with Blue, so that it can pick up her trained
traits of empathy and emotional intelligence.
The prototype that's displayed and unwisely
auctioned off by Mills is a merciless killing
machine that won't be any good to a squadron
of soldiers running with it.
Owen and Claire could easily walk away from
the fray at Lockwood's estate once they get
the pachycephalosaurus to break them out.
But instead Owen decides to hang around long
enough to ensure Wu's gene-spliced monstrosity
won't ever leave the manor alive.
That's when all hell breaks loose at the Lockwood
auction.
Twisted family tree
Poor Maisie spends her whole life being cared
for by the ailing, secretive man she knows
as her grandpa, but he refuses to even show
her a photo of the mother she supposedly lost
to land her in his care.
After he's executed by Mills, she discovers
that she's a clone of his late daughter, and
not actually his granddaughter.
In other words, it's not just dinosaur DNA
that's creating new life in this story; human
beings are also ripe for the cloning process
now.
Blue's on the move
As Mill's auction starts to fall apart, most
of the dinosaurs are still locked up in the
lower containment area.
That'd be all well and good for everyone on
site, except that the fracas eventually reaches
the lower levels, when Wu demands that Zia
and Franklin steal Blue's blood so he can
save it for the next horror hybrid he decides
to create.
The two refuse and let Blue loose on the lab
guards.
That saves them and the raptor eventually
rescues Owen, Claire and Maisie above from
the indoraptor.
But her escape causes a fire blast and a toxic
chemical leak that threatens to kill all of
the rescued dinos in cages.
Although she's spent years trying to save
these exact creatures, Claire chooses not
to let them out because it's too dangerous
to have them wandering around civilized society.
But in a twist, Maisie steps up to let them
loose anyway.
She now knows just how much she has in common
with these engineered creatures.
Outside, Owen asks Blue to stick with him,
but she decides to check out what the rest
of the world has to offer instead.
No more hybrids?
In the madness, Mills' only concern seems
to be to preserve the indominus rex bone they
fished out from the mosasaurus tank because
of how valuable it'll be to military geneticists.
However, his luck ultimately runs out, and
the T-rex eventually stomps the sample to
pieces, which means the indominus rex is gone…
but perhaps not forever?
The hybrid story could indeed continue, as
the indoraptor's skeleton is down below Isla
Nublar.
For now, though, everyone who was crazy enough
to do that initial dive is dead, so we'll
have to wait and see if Jurassic World 3 would
even bother to bring back the hybrid concept
when they've got so much else to work with.
Welcome to Jurassic World
Ian Malcolm warned everyone not to save the
dinosaurs from the volcano at Isla Nublar.
This is the same guy who once scolded the
Jurassic Park team by saying:
"Your scientists were so preoccupied with
whether or not they could, they didn't stop
to think if they should!"
And in the end, he ends up explaining to the
nation that humans now have to find a way
to adapt to and co-exist with these creatures,
lest they be wiped out by them.
For good measure, we see that scientists have
collected plenty of vials of DNA to ensure
the survival of the species, so it's not just
up to the group from Maisie's arc to repopulate
It's legitimately Jurassic World now
Humans are now on the defensive, and dinosaurs
are ready to inherit the Earth once more—
as we see in the post-credits scene, which
depicts pteranodons circling
the Eiffel Tower replica in Las Vegas.
Remember the giant Mosasaurus?
It's now on the loose, preying
on anything it can find throughout the ocean...
Even worse, the prehistoric beings seem open
to inviting the rest of modern nature to rejoin
the wild kingdom, as the T-rex breaks down
a lion's cage and exchanges a few friendly
roars with the erstwhile king of the jungle.
If and when Jurassic World 3 happens, it sounds
like it's going to live up to its namesake
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!